Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my Captain America 4 New World Order Red
Hulk video we just found out what the story is
actually going to be with red Hulk Thunderbolt
Ross and how it's connected to everything else
that's been happening during Marvel phase 4 and
during Marvel Phase 5 as well it is based on a lot
of very familiar comic book arcs if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos of course I'll do more when we get more
footage for the actual movie they start filming
pretty soon first things first if you didn't see
the news Thunderbolt Ross has been recast from
William Hurt because he passed away two Harrison
Ford so Harrison Ford is going to debut in Captain
America 4 as the new recast version of Thunderbolt
Ross it'll be just like them recasting rhodie
with Don Cheadle but all the stuff that William
Hurt did in his movies are still Canon to the
MCU even though it's going to be a new actor
the official synopsis for his character in the
movie reads the former Lieutenant General of the
United States Army and Secretary of State he was
Secretary of State during Captain America Civil
War now says during the movie he's going to be
president of the United States and then it says
using gamma radiation siphon from the Bruce Banner
Incredible Hulk transformed Ross into Red Hulk so
it sounds like during the events of the movie
or by the end of the movie he will transform
into Red Hulk and that leads directly into the
Thunderbolts movie because Thunderbolts happens
right after the events of Captain America 4 like
it's a back-to-back movie kind of situation I just
did a whole bunch of videos about Black Panther
wakanda forever and in that Movie Spoiler warning
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
in that movie Val shows up in a big way she's the
director of the CIA now as of the events of black
panther wakanda forever and she literally tells
Everett Ross that she dreams every night about the
US controlling all vibranium in the world also in
the movie Riri Williams ironheart character is
dared by one of her mystery professors to build
a vibrating detector claiming that she can't do
it the mystery Professor then turns around and
sells it for a bunch of money to the US government
it the main villain of Captain America 4 is going
to be the leader from The Incredible Hulk movie
played by Tim Blake Nelson he was on stage during
d23 like yeah it's so great to be back they're
finally doing something with my character again
my theory right now is that he was that mystery
professor and because at the end of the movie
shuri makes a deal with Namor to protect all
the vibranium on Earth his underwater vibrating
deposits that the U.S almost got their hands on
and obviously she's going to protect wakanda's
vibranium now the only way anybody in the world
can get vibranium short term is to invade wakanda
which is exactly what neymore wanted at the end
of the movie because he was hoping that shuri
would then form an alliance with him turn to him
for help and they would burn the surface world
to the ground as he prophesied earlier so they're
just setting up Val eventually invading wakanda in
a big way and probably using the Thunderbolts
to do it but obviously the Thunderbolts movie
comes after Captain America four so what's
Captain America 4 all about if Thunderbolt
Ross becomes president what they might be doing is
actually doing the transition from Secret Invasion
to dark Reign from the Comics we have secret
Invasion episodes that are coming early next
year the Hawaii and the MCU version of secret
invasion is more of a political entry kind of
thing for an evil group of skrulls has infiltrated
a bunch of Worlds governments trying to take over
the planet same basic idea but like every single
Avenger isn't going to show up as a skrull version
themselves Everett Ross is also coming back from
Black Panther wakanda forever in secret Invasion
as well that's why akoye rescued him at the end of
black panther wakanda forever so that he'd go help
Nick Fury but what they might be setting up is
that in secret Invasion Nick Fury winds up being
successful and taking down this sect of skrulls
but they find out that they had impersonated a
bunch of world leaders including the US president
which naturally kicks him out of office meaning
there's a vacancy in Thunderbolt Ross winds up
taking credit for all the things that Nick Fury
did getting rid of the skrulls just like in comic
book secret Invasion Norman Osborne took all the
credit for getting rid of the skrulls and rode the
clout that he got from that with the US government
to become the new director of shield and take over
the Avengers and replace them with a dark Avengers
but in the MCU it's Thunderbolt Ross taking credit
for everything that Nick Fury does getting rid
of all these bad skrulls and using the clout from
that to win the U.S presidency so Thunderbolt Ross
becomes the most hardcore militaristic president
in the history of the United States that might
have something to do with a Val becoming the
new director of the CIA getting away with all
this really shady stuff but that is sort of stock
and trade for the CIA if you're not familiar with
them they get involved in all kinds of Black Ops
Shady stuff and the whole idea is that coming out
of secret Invasion there's this paranoia aspect
that just drives everything through the roof so
the world is still healing from the snap the
five-year time Jump Avengers end game Thanos
that's one of the main reasons why they were
so pissed off at wakanda during black panther
wakanda forever we're trying to rebuild why
aren't you sharing all your resources your
technology your vibranium with us Thunderbolt Ross
and Val basically want to do a more militaristic
version of what Iron Man was trying to do cover
the world in a suit of armor except Thunderbolt
Ross and Valor really only thinking about the
United States not the rest of the world and
they want vibranium to do that they want a
bunch of power people who will do what they
say that's who the Thunderbolts are basically
like Thunderbolt Ross becomes the US president
he creates his own version of the dark Avengers
and they are the Thunderbolts characters here's
where we get to the whole Red Hulk the leader in
the Bruce Banner Incredible Hulk plot because the
leader's whole thing is replicating the powers of
the Hulk I think he's going to be the person who
winds up turning Thunderbolt Ross into Red Hulk
siphoning off Bruce Banner Hulk's gamma energy the
same way that they did it in the comics to create
Red Hulk if you're not familiar with where the Red
Hulk in the comics came from it's actually right
out of world war Hulk I know everybody wants World
breaker Hulk within the Marvel Cinematic Universe
when are we gonna get World breaker Hulk the funny
thing is is that comic book World breaker Hulk was
used to create comic book Red Hulk so during World
War Hulk Hulk goes full world breaker turns on all
his former friends Iron Man and the other Heroes
developed a last-ditch way to de-power him using
Earth's satellites getting rid of all this Cosmic
and Gamma energy that was inside of him while
this was going on the Intelligentcia which is
Modoc and a bunch of the other smartest villains
in the Marvel comic book Universe got together
and developed a way to hack Iron Man's special
technology that he was going to use on the Hulk
they knew that they needed a weapon that they
could control that could fight people like the
Hulk and the other Heroes they knew it was just
going to be a matter of time before they came
back for them to stop them from trying to take
over the world so in the middle of world war Hulk
while Hulk is fighting the century to a standstill
Iron Man activates his anti-hulk weapon protocol
and because it's happening in such a panic he
doesn't have time to double check the math or
make sure that everything's working correctly
he just fires the weapon off the weapon is meant
to de-power him back into Banner form so that
they can actually deal with him but while this
is happening modok who has hacked this technology
siphons off all that Cosmic and Gamma energy and
puts it into another person creating the Red Hulk
that person just happened to be the resurrected
body of under bolt Ross who was working with the
Intelligentcia She-Hulk literally just mentioned
Red Hulk during her episodes and we got a version
of the Intelligentcia obviously because they use
the intelligentcian name for Todd's group in
the She-Hulk series they'll call it something
different and because Modoc is going to be a
character in Ant-Man 3 quantumania doing something
completely different with the Kane character
the Ant-Man the WASP characters they're just
giving all that Modoc plot to the leader but the
leader was also part of the Intelligentcia that
created the Red Hulk in the comics anyway there
were even some deleted scenes in The Incredible
Hulk movie of the William Hurt Thunderbolt Ross
talking about taking the powers of the Hulk for
himself which is literally talking about becoming
Red Hulk God damn it what what's inside of them
this also makes me think that the whole scar son
of Hulk teaser at the end of She-Hulk will have
something to do with Captain America 4 and him
taking the powers of Bruce Banner Incredible Hulk
but it sounds like they are doing World War Hulk
related plot through Captain America 4 in a way
and then heading into the Thunderbolts movie that
movie will be Val trying to use the Thunderbolts
to take wakanda's vibranium what they also might
be doing too is that Harrison Ford shows up as
Thunderbolt Ross the U.S president and becomes Red
Hulk during Captain America 4 and that he's mostly
CG through the events of the Thunderbolts movie
back when they released the Thunderbolts teaser
of the initial team people were like wow that's
a small team and they're all super soldiers isn't
there going to be a whole character on that team
because in the picture if you look behind them
there's all this dead space I think the idea is
that the Red Hulk is meant to fill all this dead
space here there's also the Abomination character
we have to ask what's happening with him because
during the She-Hulk series they teased that he'd
actually become a much more chill person like he
wasn't evil anymore what they could always
do is just have Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk
wind up killing him just to prove how badass he is
because I think the whole idea is that by the end
of Captain America 4 he becomes Red Hulk so that
they can use red Hulk as a big character during
the Thunderbolts movie and a lot of you've also
realized this too during black panther wakanda
forever and heading into Marvel Phase 5 the major
overarching villain is actually the US government
so it totally makes sense that Thunderbolt Ross
would become the US president like towards the end
of Marvel phase five things are going to turn into
the dark rain era of the comics within the MCU but
everyone posts all your theories in the comments
below if Thunderbolt Ross becomes Red Hulk siphons
the gamma from The Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner
character what kind of world war Hulk plot do you
think they're going to do during Captain America
4 to sort of build up to that we'll also get a
new secret Invasion trailer really soon too so
of course I'll be doing full videos for that
just like I do for all the other Marvel Disney
plus series because they're introducing Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine and Deadpool into the MCU
during Deadpool 3 like by the end of the movie
they'll be in the MCU I also kind of wonder if
Thunderbolt Ross is going to get his hands on
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and try to replicate his
powers and that's how we get adamantium inside the
MCU because adamantium in the comics was created
when scientists in the United States were trying
to recreate vibranium they created adamantium
by accident we might see another twist like
that later in Marvel Phase 5 because Val wants all
this vibranium so they're probably trying to find
a way to replicate it I've got a bunch of bonus
videos planned this week there's a bunch of big
stuff happening in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special is going to be dropping really
soon too so make sure you enable alerts from
my channel so you don't miss that click here
for my black panther wakanda forever post credit
scene video and click here for my new Deadpool
3 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!